Because I like
to check in with you.
'Cause it's been about a year.
-Yeah.
-And this is the only time
we see each other.
-It really is.
We're like party friends
except it's not even
a party friend.
It's like a -- It's weirder.
-Yeah, we are.
It's weirder
than even party friends.
-It's weirder
than a party friend.
-But I do want to check in,
'cause you were here
about a year ago,
and you were very happy.
You were, like, proud,
and I felt like you thought
you were becoming an adult.
-I've heard whisperings of what
you're talking about earlier.
-Well, you were talking about
you had moved in to
a new apartment,
and then you said
you were thinking
about getting a dog and a car.
So I'd like an update.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Well, I don't have a car.
-Okay.
-I actually don't have
a license right now.
-Oh, no.
Why don't you have a license?
-'Cause I lost it.
-Okay.
-That's true.
-Okay, but you can
just get a new one.
-Yes, I can.
I have an appointment.
[ Laughs ] This is all real.
I have an appointment
next Monday in Santa Monica.
-Oh, so you have to go to a DMV.
-Yeah.
And just have a face-to-face.
I got an e-mail that I can take,
like, another photo if I want,
which I'd like to
'cause my license photo isn't --
It's not cute.
-What do you think went wrong
the last time
when you took the photo?
-I think I was too excited.
-Okay.
-I was, like, really --
I was, like, too --
-It is such a bummer
when you get too excited
for a license, especially when
you get pulled over
for speeding.
-Ugh!
-Because when you give that,
it looks like you were
definitely speeding.
Like, if you're a guy who...
couldn't wait to be
a legal driver.
So you don't have
a license or a car.
So that one seems like that's a
step backwards from a year ago.
-Yeah. So hopefully
a year from now
I'll at least have a license.
-A new license. Okay.
-So I don't have a car.
I am going to get a dog.
-Okay. So you have not --
In a full year,
you haven't gotten one yet.
-Haven't gotten a dog.
Haven't gotten the car.
-Lost a license.
-Right. Yes. Lost a license.
-And do you know what kind
of dog you're getting?
-So maybe we've moved backwards.
Yeah, I do.
I'm getting a French bulldog.
-Okay, great.
That's very exciting.
-I know.
They make me feel that way, too.
-Have you ever had a French
bulldog in your life before?
-No.
-Okay. Do you know --
Like, do you have any sense
of the timeline
of when you're going to get one?
-Well, uh...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, like the middle of August.
-"Well, the problem
is I got to drive there,
and that's a whole thing
because of my license."
[ Laughter ]
Maybe they could just -- They're
gonna give this dog your address
and say, "It might be faster if
you just find your way there."
-"Go find her."
Lassie, come home.
-Do you have -- Do you want
a boy dog, a girl dog?
-A girl dog.
-Do you have a name picked out?
Or are you gonna wait until
you actually lay eyes on it?
-No, I'm thinking about it.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I like --
I think, uh, like Tank.
-Okay, for...
-[ Laughs ]
-That seems like --
I mean, again, you know,
look, who am I to say?
That seems like a boy's name.
But I guess -- I don't know.
-I know.
-But, again, maybe
a girl bulldog doesn't --
-But I like it.
-Yeah. What does she care?
-She doesn't care.
-Yeah, it's just a noise.
-And where --
It's gender-normative.
Like, it's passé. Lame.
-Exactly.
Also, she's French. Yeah.
-Yeah.
What does that even mean?
-[ French accent ]
It's so American to say
Tank is a boy's name.
Tank is a name
that can be anyone's name!
-She just doesn't
play those games.
-One of my favorite things
we've ever talked about
is your first New York City
apartment sounded like
the worst apartment,
or the smallest apartment.
-Well, it was.
-What was the --
There was something.
The bed was something?
The bed was in the kitchen?
-Yes, the bed is in the --
Well, it went --
I mean, it was one room.
-Oh, right.
Now I remember the word.
-It was one room.
-Yeah.
-So it was a bitchen.
-A bitchen.
-The kitchen and the bedroom
were the same room.
So we had -- We just were like,
"Come over to our bitchen."
-I will say...
-It's the bedroom.
-...that if you got asked
to come over
to a bitchen apartment,
you'd be like, "Awesome!"
I think it's gonna be like
a wraparound penthouse.
And meanwhile it's like --
-It's like a...
couch that you're sleeping on,
with, like, a pull-out --
with one of the things,
a door over the stove.
-Yeah. Right. "I went back to
this girl's bitchen apartment."
"How'd it go?" "I knocked
my head out on a sink."
-Yeah. No, it's not.
It wasn't safe.
The truth of the apartment
is that it wasn't safe.
-But you recently got in --
Your roommate
got in touch with you?
-Oh, my roommate from that time
is one of my best friends.
-Okay. Still?
-Yeah. Hey, Tommy.
-Okay.
-I've never done that before.
-And he found something
from back in the day?
-Yeah, he recently
found this three days ago.
And I was so excited I was
going to come and see you.
I -- Seriously. I got this --
And also the subject heading
was "Dark Days."
-Dark days. So this was --
Now, this is somebody
that you've managed
to stay friends with.
-Oh, for like --
-You guys got through this.
-I mean,
by the skin of our teeth.
-This is a legal document
that he wrote up.
This is a roommate agreement.
-Yes.
-Was he a lawyer?
-No.
He's an -- he was an --
He was an actor.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
-There is so much legalese
to this.
I can not stress
how crazy this is.
-Wait. And you didn't even see
there is room
for both of us to sign
at the bottom.
And he wasn't gonna -- I don't
know what he was going to do.
-This is my favorite one.
Hold on.
"Both parties
must treat the other
with courtesy and respect,
regardless of their state
of inebriation, exhaustion,
or general
non-collaborative mood."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That is -- That's --
-Isn't that amazing?
-It's amazing that you had --
like, basically signing
a legal document
saying you're gonna --
No matter how drunk you are,
you have to treat somebody
with courtesy and respect.
-Respect. Yeah. Dignity.
We're all humans.
-The amount that he says
"both parties" is fantastic.
I'm so happy to hear
he was also an actor.
This is written like somebody
who watched a lot
of "Law & Order."
-His dad's a lawyer.
-Oh, his dad's a lawyer.
-So I feel like
he might have had his dad
proofread it or something.
-This is --
I mean, this is the best.
-He had bullet points.
-"Hitherto."
-Oh, my God!
I didn't even see that!
-"This hitherto serves as
a binding roommate agreement."
-"Not to be made null or void
unless agreed upon
by both parties."
I mean, what is that? He was,
like, a 22-year-old actor.
Let me see that.
-It's so great.
Like, what I like
to picture is
you coming home super-wasted,
being an asshole,
and him saying, like,
"Hey! Our agreement!"
You're like, "[Bleep] you!
My kitchen's a bedroom!
I don't care!
You signed an agreement!
-"[Bleep] you!
My kitchen's a bedroom!"
-You signed an agreement!
-Yeah, yeah.
-You're in a
non-collaborative mood!"
-No, that was --
I read that, and I died.
That's my favorite.
That's my favorite thing ever.
-That is the nicest way to say
somebody's being a jerk.
Yeah, it's a really nice way
to put some of my --
I guess what it's like
to live with me sometimes.
-Yeah. Non-collaborative.
-A generally
non-collaborative partner.